ce qui est l'état des lieux nous avons
eu trois vagues principales infections 2
en 2020 et une qui a atteint un pic en
janvier 2021
lors de ce pic
nous avions jusqu'à 10000 car par jour
en israël les chiffres étaient très
élevées et c'était donc le variant
britannique b1 17 qui était à l'eau
alors à l'origine de cette vague qui est
été très très difficile à contrôler et
nous avons donc ont décidé d'un
confinement très stricte pendant
plusieurs semaines mais en dépit de ce
confinement est bien là la diminution
des cas a été lente et nous avons pu
commencer heureusement notre campagne de
vaccination le 20 décembre et le 7
février nous avions déjà 40% des adultes
vaccinés et en quelques semaines
nous sommes passés à cinq ans d nous
sommes maintenant à 60% de la population
à dieu et 85% ont désormais pour nous
avons pris la décision le 7 février de
de lever les restrictions et depuis nous
avons vu un déclin du nombre de cas en
dépit du variant britannique et en dépit
de la levée progressive des restrictions
nous sommes passés de 10 mille cas par
jour à 60 ou 70 actuellement en israël
nous avons un peu moins de 10 millions
personnes d'habitants nous sommes passés
entre 0 et 1 décès par jour et le nombre
de cas sévères et et bien un chiffre
donc un nombre à un chiffre dont nous
avons pu diminuer d'un facteur 100
depuis le pic en janvier et le mois
dernier et lé nombre continue à décliner
dans la plupart des endroits
nous avons donc pu retirer
masques à l'extérieur mais les basques
sont toujours obligatoire à l'intérieur
nous avons un passeport vert c'est une
politique de passeport vert qui veut
dire que dans les restaurants
à l'intérieur dans les salles de
concerts dans les salles de compétitions
sportives
il faut soit un certificat de
vaccination avec les deux doses soit et
bien pouvoir montrer qu'on a été qu'on a
eue le sarko vide ou un test qu'ils
soient de moins de 60 de moins de 48
heures donc tout cela par le biais d'un
passeport vers ce sont ces restrictions
qui sont encore en place
la plupart des autres restrictions ont
été levées et les écoles ont été
réouvertes et fonctionnent normalement
donc je peux mentionner peut-être que
l'un des éléments que nous avons trouvé
intéressant c'est que en dépit du fait
que nous n'avons pas vacciner les
enfants avec les enfants représentent
30% de la population
donc nous ne les avons pas vacciner mais
le taux de contamination chez les
enfants continuent à diminuer en suivant
la courbe de l'ue taux de contamination
chez les adultes parce qu'une très
grande majorité des adultes sont
désormais vaccinés et peut-être parce
que en intérieur les enfants dans une
grande mesure porte encore des masques
et qu'il y a eu là cette politique de
passeport vert donc tout ceci nous a
permis de maintenir des niveaux de
contamination très bas voici
quelques-uns des éléments intéressants
que nous avons pu observer pour ce qui
est des variantes pour ce qui est du
variant sud africain et le variant
indien ici en israël
nous avons eu quelques douzaines de cas
de chacun mais en dépit cela nous
n'avons pas encore vu une diffusion
importante
de ces deux variants 90% des
contaminations sont encore dues aux
variants britannique
nous avons donc eu mené une étude en
conditions réelles
donc en collaboration avec pfizer et
dans les tout derniers dans tout
derniers résultats publiés dans le new
janeiro
eh bien nous avons pu noter 95 % de
réduction des cas sévères et nous avons
pu montrer que pour certains sous
groupes comme les patients avec
plusieurs co morbidités l'efficacité
tête un petit peu moindre
88 % avec certaines maladies chroniques
le l'efficacité était plus de plus de
80% pour les maladies rénales chroniques
et des maladies cardiaques chroniques
j'ai encore beaucoup de données à votre
disposition sur certains sous-groupes
mais je pense intéressant d'ouvrir la
discussion de manière à pouvoir répondre
aux questions sur les points qui vous
intéresse le plus donc je m'arrêterai
ici merci merci merci beaucoup pour en
effet ce propos
actuellement la vaccination se poursuit
et sur quel type de public
la campagne de vaccination de s'est pas
arrêtée nous vaccinons tout le monde à
partir de l'âge de 16 ans dans les
catégories plus âgées
nous avons plus de 90 % de couverture
dans les groupes plus jeunes nous sommes
autour de 70 75 % et chez les 16 18 ans
l'interprète n'a pas pu entendre du fait
d'une coupure dans le son
l'interprète excuses elle n'entend pas
leçon du professeur ben ali soeur est
entrecoupé peut-on lui
so sexy
donc je vais répéter à partir de l'âge
de 60 ans nous sommes à 95%
nous sommes à 75 80 % pour les les
populations adultes et entre 12 et 16
ans nous ne vaccinerons pas encore nous
attendons encore la validation et
d'avoir plus de données scientifiques
mais je pense que ça va sans doute venir
dans les semaines qui viennent pour les
12 16 ans met donc le rythme est
désormais lent car nous sommes arrivés à
une sorte de plateau maximale il est
difficile de faire mieux mais je dirais
qu'il y a encore neuf cent mille
personnes éligibles qui n'ont pas encore
été vaccinés
des collègues ont des questions est-ce
que vous vacciner les est-ce que vous
vacciner les personnes qui ont fait la
maladie parce que l'actionnaire les gens
qui ont la cofi yes we nous proposons et
recommandons une dose de vaccin à ceux
qui ont eu la maladie
donc une seule dose est recommandée j'ai
alors on va prendre plusieurs peut-être
plusieurs questions laurence cohen oui
nous pour la présidente
bonjour à tous mes collègues moi j'ai
trois questions il me semble que l'état
d'israël est le premier pays où une
licence obligatoire liée à la coved 19 a
été accordée sur les vaccins contre la
pandémie justement decaux vide
est-ce que vous pensez que le recours à
la licence d'office et le fait d'avoir
donc levé
les brevets a contribué justement
affaires de l'état d'israël le premier
pays au monde en termes de vaccination
de sa population
ma deuxième question c'est les
citoyennes et les citoyens arabes
d'israël représente environ 20% de la
population
je voudrais savoir ils ont eu donc accès
aux vaccins en même temps que les autres
mais finalement pourquoi avoir attendu
le mois de mars pour que la campagne de
vaccination concerne les huit cent mille
travailleurs palestiniens qui sont
légalement employés en israël et 35
milles dans les colonies et ma troisième
question qui me taraude c'est que il
semblerait que l'épidémie soit hors de
contrôle en cisjordanie et est ce que
israël à l'intention de livrer davantage
de doses à l'autorité palestinienne dans
les prochaines semaines alors je sais
bien que je m'adresse un professeur que
l'ambassadeur d'israël nenê n'est pas
présent donc voilà mais simplement d'un
point de vue justement analyse en tant
que professionnels de santé je pense que
vous êtes sensibilisé parce que s'il
n'ya pas effectivement une couverture
vaccinale pour l'ensemble de la
population finalement on peut craindre
que le axel que la le virus continue à
se répandre donc nous sommes toutes et
tous concernés donc j'ai bien conscience
que certaines de mes questions sont un
petit peu limite par rapport à vous
professeurs mais je ne doute pas que
vous aurez une réponse en tant que
citoyen tout simplement je vous remercie
on va prendre deux autres collègues et
ensuite vous pourrez répondre aux trois
questions
bernard bonne oui monsieur r bonjour
monsieur je suis j'ai deux questions à
poser est comment on contrôler vous
l'immunité des personnes qui ont été
vaccinées ou celles qui ont une maladie
si l'immunité et durable
et est-ce que vous avez un problème
actuellement de résurgence de cas de
personnes qui ont été vaccinées on
s'aperçoit en france que des personnes
vaccinées pas le freezer houle
astrazeneca ont à nouveau la maladie du
coeur de david et je voudrais savoir si
en israël vous avez constaté une
évolution justement de ces cas
particuliers mais ensuite on remballe de
ces reports à répond oui merci
professeur je voulais vous interroger
sur la défiance vaccinale vous avez un
bilan en matière de vaccination qui est
inégalée dans le monde et qui nous fait
rêver
cependant il ya quand même certaines
réserves
donc je voudrais savoir quelle politique
vous mettez en place pour lever les
réticences pour convaincre à la
vaccination faire adhérer à la
vaccination
parce que vous savez qu'en france nous
avons encore un tour d'anti vague ski
rôle relativement élevé et donc votre
expérience pourrait être enrichie champ
merci professeur vous pouvez répondre à
ces questions
[Musique]
oui merci beaucoup pour tout ces
questions je vais essayer d'y répondre
une par une
cheveux alors je crois qu'il ya deux
questions qui se recoupent un petit peu
comment surmonter les réticences à la
vaccination et convaincre les gens de se
faire vacciner et celles qui concernent
la population arabe au début de la
campagne de vaccination nous avons
remarqué qu'il y avait deux communautés
clés ou et bien il y avait
moins de recours à la vaccination les
upp les ultra orthodoxes et les lézards
les israéliens arabes et nous avons vu
que il nous fallait dès le début de la
campagne nous focaliser sur ces deux
groupes et après tous ces efforts nous
avons réussi à faire en sorte que ces
deux communautés sont soit un niveau un
taux de vaccination similaire au reste
de la population et c'est une réussite
qui mérite qu'on en discute comment
faire cela
eh bien il faut plusieurs choses nous
avons désigné
nous avons des sites de vaccination
dédiés dans ces lieux et dans des
municipalités dans tous ces endroits
dans ces deux communautés où il y avait
un taux de recours bien moindre à la
vaccination l'idée était de faciliter
l'accès à la vaccination faciliter la
prise de rendez-vous ou même la
possibilité de venir sans rendez vous ça
c'était le premier point deuxième point
par rapport à d'autres populations et
résidente devant la vaccination
nous avons essayé dans la campagne
nationale d'expliquer et de convaincre
soit là la sécurité de ce vaccin
donc premier point en faisant en sorte
que des des personnalités publiques se
fassent vacciner à la télé en direct eu
moi-même y compris deuxième point
nous avons eu beaucoup de données
scientifiques certaines international et
d'autres créées en israël basé sur nos
sept de données sur notre propre
population qui ont été réalisés par des
scientifiques comme moi même qui sommes
impartiaux et le public a confiance en
nous et a été intéressée
de lire cette analyse et quand nous
avons pu prouver que le vaccin était
extrêmement efficace et caen et bien
tous et toutes ces données et les
chiffres notamment revue par des pairs
ont été montrées cela a eu un impact et
nous avons été extrêmement transparent
sur ce que nous savions est ce que nous
ne savions pas et nous avons expliqué
alors nous ne savons pas quels sont les
effets à long terme de certains des
vaccins cela dit nous avons toute
confiance et nous pouvons vous dire que
et bien si l'on pense aux effets à long
terme et aux effets à court terme de la
maladie
et si nous savons nous savons quel est
le profil d'innocuité le profil de
sécurité de ce vaccin à court terme et
ça ça a été entendu parce qu'il ne
s'agissait pas seulement de confiance
mais de dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont et dernier point je pense que c'est
très important pour les ultra orthodoxes
notamment et les communautés arabes pour
qu'elle puisse se faire vacciner
c'était de travailler avec les chefs de
ces communautés
on est allé dans les communautés on
s'est assis avec leur chef avec les les
rabbins avec les maires et nous avons eu
des discussions tout à fait ouverte et
dans beaucoup de ces discussions je suis
venu discuter avec un rabbin et et je
parlais à des médecins ultra orthodoxes
et lui avec une vingtaine d'experts
m'ont écouté pendant trois heures et ça
a été diffusée et rendue publique et à
la fin il m'a dit eh bien vous savez
quoi je suis convaincu et au bout d'une
semaine il a édité une loi une règle
rabbinique qui poussait toute la
communauté à se faire vacciner donc il a
fallu les persuader et
le taux d'adhésion a été tel que
maintenant leurs taux de vaccination est
semblable au reste de la coque au reste
de la population voici quelques éléments
qui nous ont permis les principaux
éléments qui nous ont permis de lutter
contre cette hésitation et cette
réticence alors sur un autre une autre
question
toutes les personnes qui ont été
vaccinées et qui sont malades
eh bien nous suivons ça nous surveillons
ça de très très près nous essayons de
voir si nous avons une augmentation de
ce type de cas et pour l'instant ce
n'est pas le cas nous avons à nous
continuons à voir une diminution des cas
et nous menons trente mille tests par
jour et nous n'avons plus que 0,2 pour
cent de cas positifs
donc quand on parle de cas sévères et
bien on les trouve parmi les 900 milles
qui n'ont pas été vaccinés les cas
sévères ne se trouve pas chez les plus
de huit millions qui ont déjà été
vaccinées nous savons que avec le temps
nous allait sans doute nous allons sans
doute avoir et bien une augmentation des
cas de personnes vaccinées qui vont à
nouveau avoir la maladie il nous faudra
alors penser à un rappel
un de vaccins mais pour l'instant ce
n'est pas le cas pour l'instant
le vaccin semble extrêmement efficace
alors nous nous attendons à ce qu'il y
ait ces cas parce que là l'efficacité
des vaccins est de 96% et pas de 100%
donc mais nous voyons fin de ce1 mois 25
fois moins de 2 de cas de maladies que
si nous n'avions pas vaccinés et nous
avons des données préliminaires qui
semble indiquer que pour des certains
variants comme le variant sud africain
et qu'il y aurait plus de risques
de là à nouveau sur les personnes
vaccinées mais nous ne voyons pas ce
type de cas pour l'instant et ce type de
cas sévères il semble que cela soit
extrêmement localisé et ne même pas une
résurgence de la maladie dans la
population israélienne qui est très
largement vacciner j'espère avoir
répondu aux questions qui ont été posées
je suis prêt à répondre à d'autres
questions michel magnin merci même la
présidente merci monsieur le professeur
moi j'avais deux questions mais vous y
avez presque déjà répondu j'en avais une
concernant les personnes très âgées et
vulnérables en vous posant la question
de quelle stratégie avez vous utilisé
mes exemples que vous venez de donner
sur la communauté ultra-orthodoxe
m'indique quand même que vous avez dû
travailler sur les pères et la
persuasion entre pairs mais peut-être
que le réseau médical le réseau familial
le au réseau voisinage a fonctionné
femme quelle est votre stratégie quelle
a été votre stratégie pour les personnes
très âgées et vulnérables
et puis ma deuxième question mais là
aussi vous l'avez peut-être en partie
répondu qu'elles sont et quel est le
profil des personnes qui ne sont pas
encore vaccinés est ce que vous le
connaissez est ce que elles sont
majoritairement dans les deux
communauté que vous avez identifié ou
pas catherine procaccia la question
c'est vous oui bonjour bonjour madame la
présidente bonjour professeurs je
voudrais poser une question qui va dans
le prolongement de celle de bernard
bonne par rapport aux aux anticorps on
parle de plus en plus la nécessité
d'avoir une troisième dose est ce que
vous avez commencé à réfléchir à ce
sujet et est ce que vous prévoyez de
faire des tests anti port par exemple au
bout de six mois ou de huit mois dans la
deuxième injection de telle sorte de
savoir s'il est nécessaire ou pas
d'avoir d'avoir une troisième dose est
ma deuxième question je voudrais savoir
si j'ai bien compris ce que vous nous
avez évoqué par rapport aux
contaminations des enfants qui sont en
diminution
malgré la réouverture des écoles et sans
vaccination est ce pour vous la
signification que ce sont bien les
adultes qui contamine les enfants et non
pas la verse
merci ainsi corinne imbert et ensuite
quand on bat l'us open quand corinne oui
merci mme la présidente
bonjour bonjour professeur dans la suite
de la question de catherine procaccia et
dans l'hypothèse d'une évolution d'une
maladie on va dire saisonnières de
coville avez vous déjà passé des
commandes pour l'année prochaine de deux
vaccins et je suppose éventuellement de
vaccins fader j'aurais de cette question
qui concerne la bande à la vaccination
des professionnels de santé
quelle est l approche des autorités
israéliennes vis-à-vis de la vaccination
des professionnels de santé et à ce
qu'est eu un débat sur l'obligation de
cette vaccination obligatoire pour les
professionnels de santé voir que
d'autres professionnels
et puis une autre question concernant le
passeport vert que vous avez évoqué tout
à l'heure
est ce qu'il a été bien accepté par la
population et est ce qu il a évolué
entre le moment où vous l'avez mis en
place et aujourd'hui je vous remercie
vous répondrai ensuite on aura en aura
trois 3 autres questions merci merci
beaucoup
alors je vais passer en revue les
questions une par une
alors comment a t'on vacciner les
personnes plus âgées et plus vulnérables
est bien l'une des clés je crois c'est
que nous avons eu une une organisation
par les organismes qui sont justement
fournisseurs de soins
les organismes d'assurance maladie et il
se trouve que ces personnes sont
généralement attachés à l'un des
organismes qui leur fournissent des
soins vraiment du perso à la tombe et
ils sont extrêmement volontariste
extrêmement proactif et nous connaissons
tous ces patients
cet organisme d'assurance maladie de
fournisseurs de soins connaissez
personne à leurs numéros de téléphone et
nous les avons appelées nous avons
appelé chaque personne au dessus de
l'âge de 75 ans qui n'avait pas encore
été vaccinés et nous les avons appelés
et leur demander de prendre rendez-vous
et de venir se faire vacciner nous avons
même pris rendez-vous pour eux dans les
maisons de retraite nous avions des
équipes qui venaient vacciner les
personnes donc pour les vacciner
ensemble donc voilà pour la vaccination
des plus âgés et soit dit en passant nos
études et bien suggère que l'efficacité
la même de ce vaccin chez les personnes
âgées et chez les personnes plus jeunes
dit il est donc très très important de
vacciner les plus âgés car nos anciens
développe des malaises des formes plus
sévères
alors pour le profil des 900 milles
personnes dont vacciner c'était
surtout des jeunes alors il y a une
petite sur-représentation des
ultra-orthodoxes et des arabes mais pas
dans une grande mesure la plus grande
partie n'appartiennent pas à ces deux
communautés je crois que en fait nous
avons touché du doigt la en fait une
sorte de noyau de personnes réticentes à
la vaccination ou qui préfèrent
procrastiner omettre la décision n'est
encore une fois parmi les personnes
vulnérables l'écrasante majorité des
personnes a été vaccinée donc nous
n'avons pas à mener un effort pour faire
en sorte que ces personnes soient
vaccinés donc nous sommes très heureux
de la situation que nous avons en termes
de couverture vaccinale pour ce qui est
des rappels de vaccins comme je les dis
je pense personnellement aucun rappel de
vaccin sera nécessaire à moment donné
mais je ne sais pas quand il est évident
d'après les données que nous avons c'est
que six mois après le vaccin vous n'avez
pas besoin d'un rappel parce que nous
savons que l'efficacité des vaccins est
encore extrêmement haute mais nous
allons continuer notre surveillance et
nous attendons d'autres sont des
scientifiques qui peut être nous feront
changer d'avis mais c'est pour l'heure
notre approche et nous allons également
étendre ces passeports verts qui ont été
pour six mois et qui seront maintenant
pour un an
et peut-être que dans un an et il faudra
faire un rappel mais si nous ne voyons
pas de cas réapparaître eh bien nous
pourrons prolonger encore mais nous
avons assez de doses que nous avons déjà
payé pour
et bien procédé à ces rappels de weixin
nous ne croyons pas au test d'anticorps
pour décider qui va qu'il devrait
bénéficier d'un rappel
parce que nous pensons que ce n'est pas
un bon moyen de voir qui est vulnérable
ou non donc nous n'avons pas encore de
bon test pour lui pour l'immunité
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas seulement du
nombre d'anticorps il ya également
d'immunité cellulaire et tissulaire
une autre question portait sur la
saisonnalité alors nous ne savons pas
personne ne le sait pour l'instant
faudra-t-il des rappels d'ici un an il
est trop tôt encore nous nous préparons
aux différentes options mais pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de politique par
rapport à ce qui se passe se passer dans
les prochaines années il serait
prématuré d'en décider aujourd'hui
pour ce qui est des professionnels de
santé alors nous avons pris la décision
en mars de dire aux professionnels de
santé qui ne seraient pas vaccinés qu'il
ne pourrait pas travailler dans certains
services de personnes qui sont
vulnérables et donc il faut que vous
montriez que vous avez été vaccinées si
vous voulez travailler avec ces patients
vulnérables et ça c'est une décision que
nous avons prise ce n'est pas très
différent d'une décision que nous avons
pris par le passé pour les gens qui y
est bien n'avaient pas été vaccinés
n'avaient pas développé des anticorps
pour l'hépatite b et bien ne pouvait pas
et bien être opérés ou être transfusé
pour ne pas mettre en danger d'autres
passions je crois que j'ai répondu à
presque toutes les questions sur les
enfants
concernant des enfants ya ce tome
oui alors nous constatons que
l'infection chez les enfants à baisser
au même rythme que chez les adultes
en dépit du fait que les enfants de
moins de 16 ans n'ont pas été vaccinés
il ya différentes manières d'expliquer
cela lui une explication serait de dire
les enfants sont protégés par des
masques à l'école et par le passeport
vers la politique de passeport vert en
dehors des écoles et par des tests
continuent qui sont faits ce serait une
partie de l'explication je ne crois pas
que cela explique que un tel niveau de
protection
un autre élément qui entre en ligne de
compte c'est que la vaccination chez les
adultes a réduit de manière
spectaculaire le nombre de
contaminations chez les adultes et le
fait que beaucoup d'enfants étaient sans
doute contaminées dans le foyer familial
par exemple eh bien c'est sans doute ce
qui explique le déclin mais cela
n'explique pas si un enfant contaminée a
été à l'école abandonnée pourquoi est ce
que les autres enfants ne sont pas
comptabilisés cela peut expliquer quand
même pourquoi les taux de contamination
diminue
une autre explication une autre théorie
est que les enfants sont moins
contaminant pour les autres enfants en
raison d'une charge virale moins forte
ça veut là pourrait expliquer que nous
ne voyons pas une sorte de continuation
dans le cycle mais il nous faut
recueillir plus de données sur et bien
les enfants par rapport aux autres et
leur contamination leur contagiosité et
leur contamination vis-à-vis des autres
mais je nous testons déjà mais nous
devrions
testez peut-être encore plus mais je
crois qu'une grande partie des trente
mille tests que nous réalisons tous les
jours vont aux enfants donc je ne crois
pas que nous passions à côté de beaucoup
d'infections chez les enfants par
rapport aux adultes car nous testons et
énormément car vous savez beaucoup
d'enfance peuvent être asymptomatique
dont vous avez là plusieurs explications
possibles qui peuvent expliquer pourquoi
le taux de d'infection chez les enfants
a diminué de manière significative en
dépit du fait qu'ils ne sont pas
vaccinés j'espère sa réponse à votre
question très bien avant que je passe là
non parole à d'autres collègues
laurence quand même aveu avait posé une
question par rapport à la licence
d'office et à la comment on appelle ça
des brevets au brevet est ce que est ce
que c'est quelque chose qui a été
appliquée chez vous par rapport aux
vainqueurs au vaccin pfizer je ne
comprends pas de quelle brevet on parle
à ce vaccin n'est pas d'israël donc nous
n'avons pas le brevet j'ai sans doute
mal compris la question
c'est un mécanisme on en parle beaucoup
actuellement par rapport à l'europe ce
qui permet de lever la propriété la
propriété intellectuelle de producteurs
de vaccins vous vous n'avez travailler
toute façon qu'avait fighter et avec un
contrat qui est ancien et fraser donc
vous n'avez pas eu de recours
particulier en licences d'office
comment se sont faits les la
commercialisation a été d'emblée à un
accord entre le laboratoire et le
gouvernement aille
since we are being
puisque nous achetons le vaccin je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait de questions de
propriété intellectuelle car nous
n'avions en fait aucune demande sur
cette propriété intellectuelle nous ne
fabriquons rien non je ne crois pas que
nous ayons eu ce type de questions
rien n'a été produit localement et il
n'y a eu aucun transfert de
connaissances ou de technologie donc ce
n'est pas un aspect de la transaction
qui était pertinent pour le pôle israël
je ne crois pas pouvoir vous en dire
beaucoup plus là dessus
si vous voulez voir le contrat entre
israël et fighter il est sur le site du
ministère de la santé israélien
ils ont pris la décision de rendre
public ce contrat comme ça et bien tout
le chacun est libre de pouvoir en
prendre connaissance
c'est la question la parole à rené paul
savary ensuite au président van damme
oui merci alors merci monsieur
professeurs pour m'éviter d'aller sur le
site voulait savoir simplement à quel
prix vous aviez négocier ces vaccins
piercy ou le savez merci et vous n'avez
pas parlé des applications numériques
donc j'aimerais savoir quelle
application numérique vous avez pu
l'utiliser pour lutter contre le coc
vide et suivre éventuellement la
vaccination
merci je vais bien je suis à une
question sur la notion d'immunité
collective puisque au début de la
pandémie en 2020 beaucoup de
scientifiques nous expliquait pas qu'à
partir du moment où 70 % d'une
population ou la population doper d'un
pays auraient soit contracté le virus
soit été vaccinées mme à l'époque on
parlait pas encore de vaccin
le problème disparaîtra naturellement et
d'ailleurs certains pays comme la suède
et même la grande bretagne au départ
envisageait de laisser se propager le
virus pour atteindre cette immunité
collective en israël aujourd'hui vous
êtes bien au delà des 70 % 2
deux pôles de personnes vaccinées et
j'ai le sentiment que cette cette notion
d'immunité collective plus personne n'en
parle
et moi qui ne suis pas scientifique est
ce que vous pouvez m'éclairer sur le
sujet c'est à dire que ce sont les
variantes qui font que le risque est
toujours là et qu'on atteindra toujours
on n'atteindra jamais cette immunité
collective avec la disparition du
problème
dans quelle situation est-ce que nous
sommes exactement très bien et moi
j'avais une dernière question à ce
moment là c'était par rapport au neuf
cent mille personnes non vaccinées
est ce que la notion du passeport est un
encouragement une incitation à se faire
vacciner parce que ça limite quand même
certaines certaines entrées est ce que
est ce que vous avez santé qui a ça
bougeait chez ces personnes du fait du
passeport ou non est ce que je peux
répondre à lisier allez-y vous y
répondez sur la sbee alors commençons
pas prendre les questions à une par une
alors pour ce qui est du prix je n'ai
pas fait partie de la négociation de ces
marchés publics donc je ne peux pas
faire de commentaires là dessus
pour ce qui est des applications
numériques les applications numériques
ont été utilisés massivement dans notre
campagne de vaccination encore une fois
la campagne a été menée par les six vous
organismes de d'assurance maladie et d
donc toute la prise de rendez vous par
exemple s'est fait par l'ue par le biais
d'applications mobiles quand le patient
venait dans le site de vaccination le
dossier médical entièrement due maryse
numérisés et est disponible
ceux qui avaient bien considérablement
faciliter et accélérer les choses
une fois la personne vaccinée
la prise de rendez vous pour la deuxième
dose était faite automatiquement et de
manière entièrement numérisé des sms
étaient envoyés des rappels étaient
envoyés pour que rappeler leur donc il
ya eu oui utilisation de beaucoup
d'outils numériques pour ce qui est des
habilités collective
alors la question en fait dans votre
question vous parlez de différents types
d' immunité collective
ce dont on parlait avant c'était une
identité collective naturel je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des pays si ce
n'est tous ont complètement abandonné ce
type est bien deux approches
car on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
considérer que laisser les personnes
être infecté peut-être une une belle
approche on a qu'à voir ce qui se passe
au brésil ce n'est pas viable comme
politique
quand ce qui est de l'unité collective
qui serait compatible et même régis par
une vaccination je ne crois pas que ce
soit pertinent l'humilité collectif veut
dire que si vous en vous enlever toutes
les mesures de protection vous en prenez
abandonné toutes les mesures de
protection
la maladie ne se diffuseraient pas parce
qu'il ya tellement de gens vaccinés que
pour les le nombre de personnes qui
devraient être affectés et bien la
plupart seraient protégés je crois que
nous n'en sommes pas encore là car cela
voudrait dire que et bien si nous avions
un nombre n 2 personnes qui devraient
être infecté il faudrait avoir n -1 de
personnes vaccinées nous ne sommes pas
encore tout à fait ça il semble qu'il y
ait beaucoup de protection indirecte
et et dans beaucoup d'immunité et c'est
pourquoi il est sans doute très
difficile de voir des carreaux suffire
mais ce n'est pas impossible en
particulier si nous enlever enlevions
nos masques à l'intérieur ou si nous
laissions tomber le passeport vert et
pour ce qui est des variants qui
peut-être au lieu de 96 % des piquets si
les vaccins seraient à 76% et là bien de
nouveaux cas pourraient apparaître et il
nous faudrait à la fois de revenir à des
mesures à des restrictions non médical
donc on ne peut pas se dire ça y est
c'est gagné il faut que nous restions
vigilants attentifs et humble cette
maladie nous apprend de nous apprend
tous les jours nous en tirons des
enseignements chaque jour chaque mois et
nous devons jamais être complaisant
aucun pays n'a gagné cette vie cette
bataille
et en ce qui concerne la dernière
question sur le passeport vert et
passeport vert n'ont pas été mis en
place pour encourager la vaccination
ils ont été mis en place pour permettre
aux personnes à haut risque de d'avoir
la possibilité d'aller au restaurant
d'aller dans des lieux clos sans être
sans risquer d'être infectés donc avec
cette politique de passeport vert nous
avons pu réouvrir les salles de concert
les salles les restaurants pour des
personnes de plus de 75 ans qui avait
été vacciné très tôt parce qu'ils
s'étaient eux alors nous savons qui ils
sont pas 100 % protéger mais grâce au
passeport vert nous avons pu ouvrir
réouvrir ses salles et continuer notre
surveillance
je dois reconnaître que en mettant en
place cette politique
cela a sans doute encouragé
effectivement des champs à se faire
vacciner mais ce n'était pas la logique
sous jacente au départ mais je crois que
cette politique a très très bien
fonctionné en particulier maintenant
qu'une trêve si haute proportion la
population est vacciné mais rappelé
rappelez vous toujours une chose si une
personne ne veut pas être vaccinés
qu'elle veut aller au restaurant et bien
elle peut maintenant aller au restaurant
et être à l'extérieur donc mais l'idée
était de faire en sorte que les
personnes âgées ou vulnérables n'était
pas à risque
donc l'idée était de ménager un
équilibre il fallait un compromis et je
crois que nous avons essayé de trouver
ce juste milieu cet équilibre en
revanche par rapport à la levée des
restrictions parce que vous l'avez dit
vous l'aviez dit en janvier vous la
vérité
vous êtes resté sur un confinement
prescrites au début de la vaccination il
y avait une première dose y avait les
trois semaines avant la seconde dose est
à peu près trois semaines après la
durant cette période vous avez été dans
un confinement très strictes pas un
semis confinement un vrai confinement à
part combien à partir de quel moment
après les à partir du quel pourcentage
après la deuxième dose vous avez vous
avez levé ce confinement
ça c'était ma première question est mais
je ne sais pas si on peut répondre ou
est-ce qu'on en est par rapport aux à
l'ouverture d'israël à l'entrée de
personnes venant en israël ou quittant
israël par rapport à l'ouverture du pays
aux au transport aérien notamment so
when
quand nous avons imposé le confinement
c'était deux semaines après le début de
la campagne de vaccination quand on a vu
qu'il y avait eu une montée du nombre de
cas qui continuait et nous avions déjà
commencé la campagne de vaccination et
nous savions qu'il nous faudra encore
trois semaines pour que les gens soient
complètement en protection est protégé
et qu'il nous faudra encore beaucoup de
semaines pour que beaucoup de gens
soient protégés donc en février quand
nous avons décidé de lever les
restrictions 60% de la population avait
déjà été vaccinées et nous pensions que
à ce stade et nous avions encore
beaucoup plus que 60% de personnes âgées
et vulnérables qui avait été vacciné
nous pensions donc être dans une
situation suffisamment sûre pour
réouvrir et nous avons réouvert
graduellement nous n'avons pas tous
réouvert d'un coup c'est toutes les deux
semaines
nous avions une étape supplémentaire de
levée des restrictions dont toutes les
deux semaines on vérifiait que tout
allait dans le bon sens et ont passé à
l'étape suivante donc ça a été
progressif
nous n'avons pas réouvert les écoles
immédiatement au début nous avons
également réouvert des écoles pour
certaines classes et et pour ensuite les
classes suivantes pour les restos race a
été la même chose progressif ça a été
notre approche pour cette question par
an par ailleurs le pays ouvert
maintenant on voit aux visiteurs
extérieurs ou non il ya encore beaucoup
de restrictions de par rapport à
l'entrée ou à la sortie du très haut
alors il n'y a pas de restriction pour
ce qui est de quitter le pays et pour y
revenir alors il ya juste direct de
quarantaine et il faut être testés avant
d'aller dans l'avion et il faut être
testés avant de rentrer dans le pack 2
dans l'avion est ensuite quand on
atterrit et il faut une quarantaine sauf
dans certains cas où ils sont vaccinés
et il arrive dans un pays qui n'est pas
touché par certains variants sinon il y
à une période de quarantaine
l'ouverture au tourisme c'est quelque
chose qui fait l'objet d'un débat
important en ce moment et nous allons le
faire graduellement parce que nous
voulons faire attention
donc c'est une politique progressive qui
est en train d'être élaborée la
quarantaine dure combien de joueurs d'un
des dix jours et la 40ème et et
contrôler sévèrement parce que bon il ya
eu ce débat là en france mais quand on
parle de quarantaine en france on
demande aux gens de rester à l'isolément
il n'y a pas vraiment de contrôle est-ce
qu'en israël les choses ont été faites
de manière plus stricte
alors l'une des critiques les plus
importants dont le gouvernement est en
effet les faits c'était que le contrôle
n'étaient pas assez strictes sur les
quarantaines qu'il n'y avait pas assez
d'évaluation
vous savez où est il y a eu une
application de la police pour faire des
visites mais ça n'a pas été extrêmement
efficace
nous on a pensé à des bracelets des
bracelets électroniques donc on est en
train de réfléchir à ça mais nous
n'avons pas encore mis ça en place
cela permettrait d'améliorer
l'efficacité des quarantaines mais ça
n'a pas encore démarré nous voulions
démarrer un pilote mais ce n'est pas
encore le cas en question
le nombre des décès
et combien en israël le nombre de décès
est est-ce qu'il ya une beaucoup de
personnes en réanimation et est-ce qu'il
ya eu à un moment une surcharge des
services de ranimation saut alors je
vais essayer de donner les chiffres les
plus récents
les chiffres d'aujourd'hui jusqu'à
maintenant nous avons eu 6332 décès en
tout depuis le début de la pandémie dans
les semaines qui viennent de s'écouler
nous avons un mort page ou par jour en
moyenne
bien sûr dans le passé c'était beaucoup
plus mais maintenant nous sommes entre 0
et 1 décès par jour
au pic de la pandémie nous étions
proches de la saturation pour les soins
intensifs la réanimation
on était très proches de la saturation
c'est arrivé très très proches
mais nous avons réussi à faire que la
campagne de vaccination avance avant que
nous ne dépassions nos capacités nous
n'avons donc jamais atteint le point où
les capacités étaient saturés bien que
au pic de janvier nous étions très
proches à cause du variant britannique
le b1 17
écoutez merci beaucoup
professeur de cet échange qui était très
instructif pour nous vraiment en suisse
ras est là sur ce volet
de la crise sanitaire et ils nous seront
peut-être amenés à vous solliciter sans
trop abusé de vote en france est
précieux mais vraiment merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup de cet échange thank you
merci merci madame la présidente merci
mesdames et messieurs pour cette
occasion deux oeuvres m'exprimer devant
vous et je suis à votre service je suis
à votre disposition si je peux partager
les enseignements que nous avons tiré et
j'espère que est bien très prochainement
la france sera dans une situation
similaire à la nôtre
par rapport à tous les points que nous
avons évoqués et je vous souhaite
eh bien vous avez tous mes voeux je vous
souhaite le meilleur
[Musique]